way I think it's important to note that
all of the negative Downstream
repercussions of this entire cultural
psychosis only impact women right only
impact women men are not worried about
women transitioning into men and taking
their Sports record or being in there
changing rooms or being put in they're
not concerned about females entering
male prisons and so on the same is not
the true the other way around why
because the Sexes are different and
everyone knows it you may have I don't
know if you know this do you know that
there are males who are identifying as
women getting transferred into female
prisons and suddenly female prisoners
are getting pregnant how do you think
that is happening